Kaitlyn Bristowe and Jason tardik hi
okay I have to start off with this you
guys because we were talking a little
bit before this and truly I really mean
this you are the happiest I've ever seen
you okay I can't believe people I can
see that just through like Instagram cuz
I get that a lot yeah like you I mean
you know me but yeah a lot of people
have been like you can just see her
genuine happiness I'm like you wouldn't
say that yesterday cuz I'm PMSing and I
was kind of a lightness to you and an
ease around him yeah but as many times
as if you're always funny and
charismatic and everything but you seem
at ease you know what is it about him
than you not know not to take it away
from you at all because you are a huge
reason but I feel like I'm just in a
good place in life and that you came
into my life at such good timing yeah
where I'm just like overall happy I'm
feel like I'm established in things I
just feel like I'm just over all happy
and then I feel like he's kind of like a
bonus to me because he's I won't get
emotional but he's like the best person
I've ever met and I'm like oh my gosh
and he's my boyfriend like I don't know
I feel like you just you totally allow
me to be myself and he he like
encourages me yeah it's nice sometimes
tell you the real yeah you do but I need
that I need that yeah I guess
I mean I'm probing a little bit shocker
but here's the thing I've been in this
situation before where you suddenly
realize that maybe you never really knew
what a good relationship was oh
absolutely
is that how you're feeling I just feel
like I didn't realize a relationship
could be this easy and that it I could
be that happy with somebody like it's
just so easy
we've just a really really healthy
communication healthy relationship and
we build each other up yeah it's nice
yeah are you a is your silence that
going that I'm not going everything no I
think it's we have a unique relationship
and the fact I think we both have seen a
lot we've done a lot we've experienced
the good bad and ugly in relationships
and I think as you kind of mature you
know what you want and with Kaitlyn and
I we kind of have like a no BS type of
attitude we put everything out there
we're very transparent we're very
forthcoming with everything and
sometimes that leads to almost too much
of open community
the day we hold nothing back and it
allows us to grow as wanted as a team
it's been awesome yeah we have a hell of
a time doing it yeah where is the danger
area of too much communication like when
you know earlier today I take a chip
like it like a nice gentleman I chew it
with my mouth closed but it makes a
crunch and she's like can you not you
like that much tell me what you would
like drinking sounds or a trigger for me
it's a whole thing that is what you are
yeah having conflict about that's a good
thing yeah has there been anything more
significant that you've had to work
through at this point well I really need
to work I'm putting the toilet seat down
after it's like it got triggered there's
not one yeah no I don't know I mean we
just moved in together what like a week
ago yeah so I feel like more to come
about and we're doing we're doing crash
course right we rescued the dog we move
in together so we're doing it all at
once we're learning how we pair it how
I'll take the dog yeah so it's a crash
course that it's going well oh ask you
crazy I mean you've both been in
relationships before how did you sort of
know it is a good idea for us to dive in
on these big things kind of all at once
because moving in together adopting a
dog together it's like a baby I mean how
did you decide no we want to do all this
right now I feel like we just had the
confidence in our relationship
yeah how they sound I think the whole
crazy thing about this whole bachelor
world is it like guts you up it opens
you and you talk about everything and
anything and you become comfortable with
yourself your emotions and I think
because that that's why you see so many
people within the franchise have
relationships whether it's via podcast
or on a show or paradise or whatever so
for you and I we were just like so open
we know what we want we know what we
don't want and
[Laughter]
well it's I mean--but you know before
when I asked you about it you said I
don't want to get emotional which it
always think you know I think hey it's
kind of amazing that you're with
somebody who can take you to that place
that quickly though where you thank God
I could just get emotional talking about
what a great guy here yeah he softens me
up I just I don't know I just feel well
maybe it's because I'm PMSing to you I
just feel like sometimes I just get
emotional from like just where I'm at
yeah I'm like what took me there and I'm
just I don't know I'm just happy I've
always thought of you as this person who
is so independent such a hustler you've
worked so hard to build this brand for
yourself but was there something missing
in that now you feel like you have
somebody who is pushing you even for
them and you could push yourself yeah I
am yeah I just feel like we're such a
good team where I do like I want to come
up with all these like you know the wine
label that's coming out in the
scrunchies and I work with my team and
I'd like to think of myself as like
having a creative mind where he's like
the brains not that I'm not smart he's
where it was yeah he's very business he
and I just feel like we work really well
together and it's there there's no
competition it's like we're both just
super happy for each other when we have
things going on and we help each other
more than then feel like there's any
kind of competition yeah so you move
into the house in Nashville mm-hmm
do you bring any of your stuff is this
fully furnished well what is this moving
process like also majority my stuff I
gave to a friend who's who just bought a
home but we have to redo a lot of the
house
so we're working on doing a lot to the
house and I think eventually we'll flip
it here sooner than later yeah but you
believe like your yeah you sold most of
the stuff that was in your heart is this
the house in Nashville that you were
living in before okay so I I decorate it
with this girl Jessica McCarthy and I
made it like exactly what my dream home
would be like I picked out everything
with her and with her and so but we only
did the bottom level of
Hausa there's still a huge bonus room in
another upstairs I'm like totally
Tooting my own horn that I have a big
house here but like there's other rooms
that we're gonna work on together and
then eventually um yeah sell it and then
find a find our home yeah so half the
home isn't touched so there's not one
thing on the other half so we have to
completely redo that then my dad and I
went through the first weekend just like
home stuff like basic things like
changing your air filter I'm learning a
lot I have a landscaper save it clean it
build it sell it yeah I'm the next one
okay I'm gonna ask you a tough question
here it's part of selling it I mean I
understood this house to be the house
the you shop yeah so is that part of
selling it is this weird at all no we
talked about that obviously before
moving in but I think because I hadn't
it's not like we've built it together
and we designed it together it was very
much just like it always felt like mine
to the point where even when the breakup
happened he was like obviously this is
your house like you did this and so it
just feels like now something that it
doesn't have bad energy or bad juju in
there like it just feels like it's kind
of my design and then we're gonna make
it our own and everywhere else in the
house and then we're selling it because
I always had planned to sell it anyways
in Nashville because Nashville market is
hot I've always actually planned on
selling it yeah okay and have you guys
talked at all I mean he went on a
podcast talked about the breakup a lot
yeah that was we have an interesting
podcast just because I was like I didn't
want to really talk about it just
because there's you know two sides to
every story just I didn't want it to get
like you know miscommunication or
something gets lost and you know so when
he did the podcast we talked about it
and I was like well that's you know he
can have his own feelings and I can know
the truth and he can have his truth and
it just doesn't matter at the end of the
day yeah I was like do I address
anything on my podcast but you know I
just had moved forward already so I just
didn't want to you know go backwards at
all and so no we don't we don't talk
I mean sometimes I'd like to go steal
the dog but no
no no I know you love those dogs okay
gotta ask you two about you know there's
some big bachelor news has just broken
yeah Lauren Bushnell engaged in on a
ring and I was like look it's exactly
what I was really yeah it's very similar
yeah no that's the congratulations to
them but yeah that's I mean I I
definitely saw that one coming and I was
like any day now they're gonna get
engaged like it just felt like that was
the next steps but yeah I mean we talked
about it it was ironic yesterday we had
lunch in LA and it's the table next to
us is doing wedding planning Kalin's
like looking over there I'm looking over
there we're talking also I'm Kaylen side
Pinterest looking at different kind of
cool yeah yeah I mean that's why we
moved in together cuz we were just so
ready to take the next step like we just
had again the confidence in our
relationship to take that next step
where now that's naturally something we
talked about anyways but yeah it's weird
when it does move that fast but again we
come from bachelor world where this is
actually taking it slow like we've been
together five years just coasting the
other things we're not getting any
younger
yeah I mean we both know what we want I
think before getting engaged it makes
sense to you know to move in together
and see what's next make sure you guys
have talked wedding we've yeah talk to
you know what kind of ring you want oh
yes wow I got told but that is not looks
like a Super Bowl ring okay I was like I
don't really care well what I really
like is just a simple band with a jig
fatty Rock big fatty rock and a simple
band yeah so it's perfect angle right I
like rectangle like square and I like
round just not teardrop not nothing
against it because I like those two just
not on my hand I have boy Hans you have
teardrops on your hands I've tear dry
really messed up my hands were like you
know I've got tattoos and I bite my
nails it's
really I just you know I just want
something that can like just make my
hands a little cuter I mean I look I
think you like you guys said you come
from this world where things move
quickly you're at an age that you're at
is there an just an element of like this
is working and it feels easy and let's
follow our happiness exactly and I think
that's exactly what we're doing and I
think that's why it is so easy is that
we're not fighting anything you know
we're just like surrendering to how we
feel and what comes naturally to us yeah
yeah and I mean I'm speaking on myself
again here but like I guess I I
sometimes I wonder if you felt this way
but you sort of feel like you were in a
place for awhile where again maybe you
didn't even know like how stagnant you
were and then like all of a sudden
everything clicks yeah things happen
very quickly it's looking back now I do
I was like maybe I was a little lost or
maybe I didn't you know I I didn't
understand how I felt like now I just
feel so confident in my feelings and I I
think it's hard to come off that show to
be honest like for anyone and just it
just wasn't I mean you want something to
work cuz it's the show and you want
something to be right but it just wasn't
right and that's what it all comes down
to yeah yeah I think change today is
like the only constant and I think so
many people are afraid of changing
they're afraid to take risks and
sacrifice and know that there can be
independently strong to find happiness
whatever means that is whether it's
going out a TV show seeing how it works
or doesn't work but I think in both of
our situations we had to make change to
find one another difficult decisions at
times and in difficult times but we did
that and yeah it's crazy
just things change like how things
quickly shift from like I'm I'm very
open about certain things obviously
everything not certain things everything
and like I was really in a really really
dark place for awhile just so confused
and then you know I'm like when you're
in that place you think that the world
is ending and you're just so sad and
then it's like weeks later I'm the
happiest I've ever been so I always say
that on my podcast I'm always like
because I have a lot of young girls
listening and you know they think life
is so tough but it's like you don't know
what's around the corner yeah
dong I think what's also hard to is like
we sometimes you know you want to share
your happiness but you didn't
necessarily share all the depths of your
sadness like maybe that feels hard yeah
and so I think sometimes people might
perceive I turned this quickly but they
don't know everything you really got
this exactly yeah I mean ask my
girlfriend over there she was late night
call okay uh so we're talking wedding
then we talked about kids oh yeah we
just talked about the great really
really think about this timeline though
when you finish the show it's usually a
month or two before the lead starts
again yeah and they're engaged another
month or two later oh I can't tell you
okay I mean I'm fine with one or two I
used to want five but now I'm like okay
I'm turning 34 tomorrow and then like
you know one two dogs three kids oh wow
okay we didn't I didn't know that three
I didn't know you wanted maybe I did
three does sound nice but I know will
that that probably won't happen
that sounds nice hope you have some plan
for the birthday yeah what am i doing
TBD okay can't share surprises okay Wow
he's right we were like talking about it
and it
we had like it was like a little bit of
a surprise we're some close friends were
there and I was like here we go it's
like every day I'm like today yeah yeah
love it okay
we actually Chris Harrison I don't know
if you know um he actually got me set up
at Callaway golf I'm not too long ago
and our dads are gonna meet for the
first time get custom fitted for clubs
they're together yeah we got it for them
so I'm like Kaitlyn's family and Kalyn
has been my family but they haven't
it'll be great leave that he coordinated
a golf outing for the magic okay we got
to talk about a little uh bachelor
bachelorette news yeah your boy Blake
talk to me about paradise there are
rumors that he might be getting into
some trouble there had been rumors that
he has dated Christina Shulman there was
some talk about him flirting with Hannah
gee what do you think Blake's gonna do
on paradise what are you worried about
or feeling positive about see going into
paradise I thought that him and Hannah G
would be I heard Hannah on Kaitlyn's
podcast I know Blake I thought they
would be a great couple
so I was kind of hoping for that so I
don't know if if that will come to
fruition or not but I hope that you know
what the advice I gave Plake was like
follow your heart and be smart about how
you follow it especially because
Paradise has so many twists turns in
drama the only thing is I'll always you
know there's always two sides to every
story so you know so my my thought with
Blake is how in hell mode is he gonna be
crying all seasons yeah but he's also
you know I think going into this he's
probably the most just my opinion
probably the most sought after guy there
it's gonna be you know he just how is he
gonna handle it is the question mark
how does any guy like you're a
good-looking guy you've got how there's
probably gonna be like five beautiful
women wanting to like you know be with
Blake and that's gotta be hard you know
it's it you know tough life Blake that's
gotta be hard to juggle and try and
please everybody because trust me dating
more than one guy at the same time it's
very hard yeah even when more than one
person it's really hard and you just
constantly hurt other people's feelings
and then the whole world gets mad at you
when you're just doing what anyone else
would do your prediction is the Blake
show yeah the black shirt okay the
Blake's show um what about Hannah Hannah
season is under way I will say that I
think Hannah in terms of her
independence
her humor and owning who she is she
reminds me of you Ola like she is the
Bachelorette who's probably done that
the most since you what do you feel
watching her season do you see those
similarities yeah I see it
like I like that she speaks her mind and
I mean she's a little saucy err than me
yeah yeah yeah I'm saucy but she is
she's spicy sauce like she's really
comes in hot but I I appreciate that
because I don't feel like she's trying
to be who she thinks she should be on
that show I think she's really been
Hannah and I think whoever she picks
it's gonna be like not surprised after
like they're not gonna go home and she's
gonna be a different way we're getting
like the true Hannah and I mean you
gotta give her credit because you know
you're gonna get backlash and you know
you're gonna get hated on on the
internet but she's seems to just be like
well whatever this is for me and well
you've talked about the incredible
backlash that you got yet on the show
being shamed being shamed for your
sexuality what do you think hannah has
ahead for her based on what we've seen
is coming up I mean Jesus might still
love her but I'm not sure the bachelor
nation world I'm I just want her to like
just call me Hannah call me look like I
will talk you through everything the
internet is not kind to people who women
who talk about their sexuality they're
just not and what you have to do is just
know that it's I mean she put it out
there it's who you are and you can't be
ashamed of it and you just have to stand
by your decisions and and who you are
and and it'll all turn out in the end
the way it's supposed to because it's
just whenever you're true to yourself
things work out you might go through a
rough patch but in the end it'll work
out for you because being true to
yourself is the best thing you can do
there's also unwritten rules this season
that are being crossed right when you're
as a cast member you understand
she's dating other guys you understand
when the fantasy so he comes around
there are three other people but an
unwritten rule is that when you're in
the relationship you talk about your
relationship and really don't get into
the weeds about some of the specifics
associated with what's going on and in
that trailer we saw just the opposite of
that I
I'm sure that we've ever seen anybody on
the show ask the lead have you had sex
with other people
that is crazy and what's gonna be
interesting to me to see is who will get
more backlash for it Luke Wright or
Hannah yeah my guess is that Hannah will
get major backlash for talking about
having sex on the show it's just so
interesting because we're you know we're
in a time where it's becoming more of a
normal conversation but in bachelor
world it's still so like faux pas - is
that the word for possum yeah to talk
about it and it's like it's such a gray
area like where is the line because it's
like people watch the show they know
there's fantasy suites they know there's
sex that goes on in the fantasy suites
it's just what Alton we're talking about
and it's like like you know and it's at
first when the Bachelorette started it
was like I can't believe they would have
one women dating all these men or I
can't believe all these women date one
guy and now it's like that's such a
normal thing and that we're like okay
can't wait to tune in Monday night but
now it's like sex is becoming a topic
but it would be interesting to see what
the assumption - the public eye is with
the fantasy suite because for so long
there never was that whole after the
morning of video taping thank just a
couple weeks yeah then they do the
morning after then you start to think
and now it's out there so I'm curious
what the public reaction will be yeah
would you advise a Bachelorette to not
talk about whether she'd had sex with
contestants or not just because of the
backlash or what would you defend no I
don't think you should not do it because
of the backlash I think you should talk
about it with whoever you pick and have
open conversations about that but I
don't think you should worry about the
backlash because you'll get backlash for
eating a banana it's you're gonna get
backlash no matter what putting yourself
in those shoes if Luke you know if you'd
been the one in that conversation with
Luke pee how would you have reacted well
it's so funny cuz we talked about this
that she's so decisive with everything
she does but with Luke pee she's so
indecisive and I'm we don't get it as
viewers but we don't you know you can't
judge somebody for how they feel but I'm
just like just just by just get you know
that he's my guy if you're sitting there
with him with a guy and the guy is
telling you if you've had sex with other
guys I'm out of here
oh that conversation oh yeah yeah I
shake it I'd be like Oh
like yes you wouldn't want to be ya do
you think that there's and I don't know
if you have any like behind the scenes
context into how all this goes but is it
approached differently with like the
fantasy suites and all that how does
production approach it with you as a
leader or and if at all differently as a
female lead like did they give you
advice on how to handle it do they what
do they tell you now they don't really
give you advice you I mean they are like
your only friends and people you talk to
it when you're in that world so I feel
like you talk to them just as friends so
they I don't know if they kind of go off
different people like what you're
feeling you know do you know what I mean
so I don't feel like they necessarily
give you advice they're more just
talking with you through it like how you
feeling yeah yeah and they'll direct you
is to what the day will look like and
when they'd come in the morning things
like that have a really embarrassing
question all right guys okay say that
somebody wanted to get busy outside the
fantasy suites which has happened on the
show before
mm-hmm how do you approach that with
production cuz you're like out and like
maybe you've got your clip like do you
well here's the thing they don't let you
hang out with the people outside of like
yeah and if they do I'm like learned the
hard way that if if they do that they're
up to something
like you can't if I was you know on the
show and let's say a Ben was like hey
can I see Kaitlyn they'll be like what
cameras have to be on you have to be
miked like this you can't just hang out
with them got it off camera okay I'm
still in contract also I give the ring
back did you know yeah I have no idea to
do like I sometimes I forget I even have
it still just because you know what what
am I gonna do with it I don't know them
together
[Laughter]
some news also came out about Jed a
front-runner a report that he had a
girlfriend up to right before going on
the show everyone does is that I mean it
seems to me like we get the story every
season and yet people freak out about it
every season now what do you both think
I guess when I heard that I was like
yeah I was waiting for that like I was
waiting for someone to have a girlfriend
happens every season but I mean it can't
judge anyone for it because sometimes
you really have no idea you're gonna
fall in love on that show and you're
like you know what I'm gonna go here for
the opportunity maybe I'll see you when
I get back yeah and we'll see what
happens and then you go and you actually
find love and you're like whoa I didn't
think that was gonna happen so it's not
like he he might have you know had he
admitted he had different intentions
going into the show yeah so so I stuck
when when Jed had said that his
intentions were to go on the show and
promote his music business I stuck up
for him because I thought it was great
to be proactive about what you're doing
and how that has changed but I think if
you'd now correlate him openly putting
it out there that his only intention was
to promote his music business and then
you couple that with some of the
comments that his girlfriend are now
saying about the night before and then
you tie in the twist of the gentleman
who was there the night before the night
one who had a girlfriend and you saw
Hanna's reaction he go down that road of
people saying well Hanna what kind of
standards do you have and she's gonna
have to address all that yeah sure yeah
I mean like it I think is as like this
season goes on different things come out
about different people and like that's
got it's got to be challenging down
don't work through that and then you
know talk to each person and things like
that it's just so crazy how much can
come out because of the internet now I
mean I know they released some of the
guys early this season like for that
recent like see if they could sense out
the internet could be background check
which makes sense last question for you
guys about the show I think that this
season is in uncharted territory with
how much religion is being discussed and
Hanna has said that she's grateful they
showed it because they even in the very
first episode showed her like praying
before she went out with the guys and
everything
did you experience other people like
talking about their faith talking about
religion that kind of never made it to
edit I had a very deep conversation with
Ben Higgins about religion because he's
quite religious and we did go there it's
just I think they don't usually air that
stuff because of I don't is it boring TV
maybe maybe boring maybe kind of people
say don't talk about religion and
politics you know I mean Rebecca had
asked me about politics then she asked
me who else in the house and where they
stood and I said those are conversations
you have to have and I think this did
even goes back to you know the JED
scenario or other scenarios you wonder
you know right now we're down to what
six people how many people are left
weirdly there's like some of the
conversations you see post-show if they
would be down to or if it would
influence the left the people that are
on there right right so do you think the
show should get into those topics more
absolutely I do
yeah like they're important
conversations yeah yeah I think if when
you're in a relationship and you're
talking about a family and raising a
family I think you should know at least
people stance on critical things you're
getting doors at the end of it and this
is gonna be your partner you should know
where they stand with these topics and
especially like even you should have
money conversations hell yeah like how
you were raised to think about money how
like tough conversations should be had
if you're gonna actually make this
relationship and I think that's what
we're seeing on it so it's like Hannah's
the last episode
Hannah was losing it cuz she's like all
we're talking about and all you guys are
talking about is Luke P I want to get to
know you great and I want them to get to
know her late and she wants she wants
something you guys I mean you both
obviously made it very far in your
respective seasons if you had had more
of those conversations or been
encouraged to have would your outcome
have been different no or maybe would
your experiences after the show have
been different like would you know
didn't I guess I'm essentially as did
you and Sean have like bigger
conversations to get through once
filming was ended because you didn't act
like they didn't oh yeah we did it's
just they didn't again didn't air it so
yeah so you did talk about some that
stuff during filming yeah got it it is
uh it's it's I have to admit stuff I'd
like to see more because I sometimes
feel like I'm watching two hours of them
being like
today was amazing did you humble - do
you believe in [ __ ] etcetera but yeah
she made a great point when she was like
you guys don't even know I am here or
anything about me I was like oh damn
yeah so you guys are busy bees
yes living in Nashville together does it
feel like you're living together yet or
do you travel so much for working - all
these things that it hasn't sunk in yet
I feel like we have been traveling so
much since I moved in that I'm like I
still need to unpack everything yeah so
the days we have had there have been
fantastic and we wake up with coffee we
joke around we have this Power Hour we
sit down and like talk about business
things of what we have going on and
we'll end our end their night with a
glass of wine and I've enjoyed every
minute of it yeah I mean are you ending
your night with a glass of your wine
yeah thank you oh great does it feel to
freaking have your own why honestly it
is a dream come true I'm not just saying
that it since I had my first sip of wine
ever in life I was like like this is
this is what I'm supposed to be doing
like everything in my life has led me to
have a wine label this man everything
it's just like oh here we are
we have arrived I'm supposed to be here
it is delicious like you will tie I am
always like very critical and we talk
about things and I like give feedback
this wine is especially for the price
point is so smooth for success Kaitlyn
you've got you can pull our hair back
with the scrunch we can listen to the
podcast on the vine we can drink it the
last the wine during it and we can
aspire to a great relationship would you
guys do a reality show together I think
so
Oh have a lot of fun yeah yeah yeah okay
any advice for Hannah moving forward
with the rest of the season Hannah if
you're watching this I support you and
it's gonna be a rough go buckle up but
call me because I have your back
how hard was it for you when you were
going through that it was the worst I
think I I genuinely can't like I
couldn't sleep I would cry every night I
lost so much hair
I was just I felt so defeated by
everybody but I was like I wouldn't
change a thing because this is how this
is you know you it doesn't work even if
it didn't work you just don't get to
where you're supposed to be by being
someone by trying to be somebody else
you just don't so it's hard it's really
hard and people you know always think
you're a character on TV they don't
actually think for two seconds that
you're a real human being with emotions
and these feelings and that you know
it's hard when somebody even says like
Oh your hair looks terrible like that
you're like ouch and you can't even
imagine the words that come out of
people's mouths for what they attack you
with and it sounds like honestly a lot
of the fandom does have a long way to go
with how we look at women talking about
their sexuality and movie versus men oh
absolutely
yeah it's it's wild like Colton's verdun
virginity was such a big thing too
though but it was almost more like like
a funny joke yeah yeah
you